good show though would you survive you
think no
there's no [ __ ] way
the honey i was actually thinking about
that the whole time the honeycomb thing
if i got the umbrella i'd just start
crying yeah i would just eat the honey
yeah and then this is what it says the
last meal yeah i would just cry eat the
honeycomb and then just like look at the
guy in the pink suit like
it's just really yeah
i like the one guy that got he got one
of them off like he killed one of them
before one of the guards before he that
was like his last oh yeah that was
during the honeycomb right yeah he's
like all right [ __ ] this
he like beats the [ __ ] out of one of the
guys yeah he like did you promo and took
the pistol and then
i was like all right dude yeah yeah you
know
at least you took one of them with
exactly i love how they already made
this [ __ ] in roblox yeah did they yeah
love it marcus linked it to us but like
i'm
i'm fascinated with how quickly roblox
just
they can
what even is that game like they remade
gta they made squid game they have like
that weird russian roulette game
is this like the developers of the game
writing this [ __ ] in no i think it's
people making mods okay got it it's a
literal four-year-old that made this
straight up he'll play with no audio i
don't want to hear the audio
wait okay so
you can actually play red light green
light as a squid games guy and then you
get do you get shot yep
what yeah what the [ __ ] yeah
bro i i
i don't like this crazy who has enough
time
to create this literally in like two
days 10 year old
a 10 year old that's what i'm saying
they got nothing else to do they
definitely know how to code already i
don't even think you know how to code i
feel like it's it's pretty visual like i
think you just probably like upload some
pictures and
you know yeah like i'm sure they have
like a creative mode yeah and you just
like make a map and then
that's it
so it's just like roblox is just the
ultimate platform so you can create
anything in there kind of yeah how is
debating making a video
kind of on this but more so
just me
trying to learn how you even get into
this you know what i'm saying like but i
found out there's no real meat there
this is like a website that's popular
and
random people just make [ __ ] like
there's
i couldn't believe this
there's a server spelled the hood d a
yeah and it's like
it's like people just it's like grand
theft auto that's what like they're
replicating
and there's like others that are like
south south side chicago parentheses
realistic okay
i don't think it's realistic to be a
lego person
in south side chicago right you know i
guess they're like sort of like
free-for-all servers but you've seen
those tick tock clips right
where it's like i can't believe they
shot up the party
it'll be like a bunch of people in like
in an apartment party in roblox and then
someone goes in there like shoot someone
it's like pop pop pop and everyone in
the party runs away and is it kids still
playing this is not roblox just for like
that's eight-year-old yeah that's the
part i'm like kind of
i that's what i'm curious about do you
go in there and is it just like
nine-year-olds thinking it's funny but
it doesn't seem that way because there's
a there's another tick tock clip of
these dudes they sound like they're
at least high school okay and they're
playing russian roulette
okay like they're passing a gun around
shooting in the head and one of the kids
is like dude what is even roblox anymore
yeah
so
yeah
anyway yeah would you survive you know
it's reached an older generation when
when you see that there's a there's a
squirt room
yeah
whatever the [ __ ] was the clubhouse
the final one i think i'd die
like the fight to the death yeah you
have to kill someone with a steak knife
yeah get to the yeah that's pretty rough
a knife fight i don't want to do that
yeah
yeah i know that was also the glass one
i was like
this one sucks it's just completely
random
yeah you can really do besides what the
brother did that was some people's
complaint like oh
everyone had a fair chance but now they
don't have a fair chance and it's like
you kind of do everyone has a 50 50.
well i guess no if you're last you have
a greater yeah shot yeah but yeah i love
that shot where they all grabbed it and
they had like that formation and they
all leaned back yeah that [ __ ] was dope
i was like damn yeah sick that was super
sick i like how they played it
like you thought they were gonna win and
they started getting owned
and you're like oh [ __ ] maybe the old
man is wrong
[Laughter]
yep the whole thing
yeah it was good the whole thing was
great and and really realistic
super realistic
do you think you would even stay after
one game
you kind of you kind of have to
no you'd leave for sure
but do you think you would like okay
because you know how the the majority i
guess at that point they all chose to
came back yeah so yeah yeah nah
but like that i guess that was the whole
point is that like this debt is so like
strangling
that it feels like we're in this game
anyways in the real world yeah so we
might as well play
yeah for a billion dollars or die yeah
or whatever it was how much was it
how much was it
like 45 billion won i think it came out
to
200 million i think yeah it was it was a
there was uh some like tick tock from
some dude being like me like using my
calculator on my phone the whole time
yeah to figure out how much money
they're talking about i was like i was
doing that yeah exact same thing yeah
what would uh
american squid games be do you think
american squid games would be like be
funny if it was like hot dog eating yeah
frat games pledging games you have to do
an elephant walk
do you know what that is
yeah a 400 person elephant walker
that's just how would you lose though
that's just woodstock 99. yeah yeah
exactly this is
how would you lose
if you nutted
dude stop stopping you're jerking me off
stop stopping
that's so good they make the ground like
rumble a little bit no wait why is the
ground shaking dudes don't don't sorry
sorry dude i'm not
i'm not
every time you stop you jerk me off
every time you stop at the start and the
guy behind me is jerking me off
quit it
isn't it the thumb in the ass
oh i thought it was like i thought it
was like a long reach-around train
it might be i thought it was a thumb in
the ass and then i never did this by the
way please know that i never did this i
swear to god dude but you know if i did
i would have won
[Laughter]
so
okay thumb in the end moving your thumb
dude stop stopping you're hitting my
g-spot
stop stopping you keep going really deep
you're hitting my prostate
dude it could be like
it's like one of those things where you
know
when some people get their prostate exam
to get like a instant hard-on and like a
[ __ ] erection you're like that famous
story on red is like the doctor reaching
in my ass and like my dick was so hard
he could bend his steel bar around it
yeah picturing them all lining up for
the american squid game
and someone goes to line the thumb
they get shot right away
player four has been eliminated
oh [ __ ] don't get hard don't get hard
don't get hard
you can't get up
you have to be soft dude stop stopping
you're making me hard
[Laughter]
keep hitting my g-spot dude you're
making me hard
[Music]
you